la alerta la lanzó la autoridad que
administra las líneas de alta tensión en
Francia en enero hay un alto riesgo de
cortes del suministro eléctrico esto
debido a que este país depende sobre
todo de la electricidad producida en las
centrales nucleares pero muchas de ellas
son muy viejas y necesitan mantención y
están detenidas también están parados
cuatro reactores nuevos pero que han
presentado problemas de corrosión como
hubo una huelga en el sector nuclear esa
mantención no ha ido a la velocidad que
esperaba las autoridades y por lo tanto
la producción no ha aumentado el riesgo
alto es en enero pero hay que decir que
las autoridades han advertido que hay un
riesgo durante todo el invierno eso va a
depender del nivel de consumo de los
franceses pero también de la rudeza de
esta estación hay que decir que los
franceses justamente han disminuido su
consumo de Electricidad después del
verano en un 5 un 7% quizás escuchando
los llamados de las autoridades a la
sobriedad de energética Pero eso no ha
sido compensado por un aumento en la
producción de energía por los problemas
que
de citar En todo caso un 53% nada más
del parque nuclear francés está
funcionando y por lo mismo Hace algunos
meses ya las autoridades anunciaron que
iban a importar electricidad desde
Alemania